ترحيب دولي وعربي باتفاق السعوديه وايران
وتطلع لاسامه في استقرار المنطقه
بريطانيا وفرنسا تبداان الانتاج المشترك
لاسلحه بعيده المدى وتدريب البحريه
الاوكرانيه
ما يبرر ان لا يكون هناك سفير لتونس في
دمشق قيس سعيد يبدي عزمه اعاده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه المقطوعه مع سوريا منذ عام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر في
تصريح للعربيه قال الامير فيصل بن فرحان
وزير الخارجيه السعودي قال ان الاتفاق مع
ايران جاء نتيجه محادثات استمرت لعامين
وتفاهمات مبنيه على حسن الجوار
هي نتيجه لمحادثات استمرت لسنتين وصلنا في
نهايتها الى تفاهمات مبنيه على حسن الجوار
واحترام سياده الدول ومعالجه كافه تحديات
الامن الاقليمي من خلال هذا الحوار
وانقناعه المملكه العربيه السعوديه ان
الحوار هو الاسلوب الانجع الى معالجه كافه
الامور
ومستقبل العلاقات السعوديه مع طهران ذكر
وزير الخرجه السعوديه ان المملكه تنظر
بتفاؤل لها مؤكدا ان الحوار هو الاسلوب
الانجع لمعالجه كافه الامور
ننظر بتفاعل الى المستقبل ونعمل على توطيد
العلاقه وخدمه المصالح جميع دول المنطقه
وحمايه امن المنطقه وهذا ما نط وحيده ان
شاء الله
وفي اول تعليق من واشنطن قال المتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي قال
ان واشنطن على علم بتقارير استئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين ايران والسعوديه
واكد ان الولايات المتحده ترحب باي جهود
تساعد في انهاء الحرب في اليمن وخفض
التوتر في الشرق الاوسط
وزير الخارجيه التركيه مولود شاوش رحب هو
الاخر في اتصال هاتفي مع نظيره السعودي
الامير فيصل بن فرحان رحب باتفاق استئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين السعوديه وايران
كما جرى خلال الاتصال استعراض العلاقات
الثنائيه بين البلدين وسبل لدعمها
وتطويرها في مختلف مجالات التعاون
وفي تصريحاتنا العربيه كان متحدث باسم
وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه احمد الصحاف ان
استئناف العلاقات بين السعوديه وايران
سيفتحوا حقبه جديده في المنطقه
مرحله جديده من العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
ستاخذ قدم المبادره باتجاه توطين استقرار
المنطقه اكثر وتبادل التعاون وتعزيز
مسارات التنميه نحن نتحدث عن بلدين جارين
للعراق ونتحدث عن قوتين فاعلتين في هرم
القوى على مستوى المنطقه حينما تتكامل
الجهود المشتركه وتتحول
المسارات صلبه العمل الدبلوماسي وتبادل
التنسيق والتعاون والحوار بوصفه سبيلا
لتجاوز التحديات اذا دخلنا في عتبه جديده
رحب الامين العام لمجلس التعاون الخليجي
جاسم البداوي باستئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه السعوديه الايرانيه واكد دعم
المجلس لما ورد في البيان المشترك مشددا
على الترحيبه بكافه الخطوات المساهمه في
تعزيز الامن والسلامه في المنطقه البديوي
قال ايضا انه يتطلع الى ان يسهم الاتفاق
في تعزيز الامن والسلام العالميين
ترحيب اممي وعربي بعوده العلاقات السعوديه
الايرانيه الامم المتحده رحبت بالتقارب
السعودي الايراني لانه ضروري لاستقرار
المنطقه وشكرت الصين لقيامها بدور الوساطه
الامارات اكدت على اهميه التواصل الايجابي
والحوار بين دول المنطقه لترسيخ مفهوم حسن
الجوار الخارجيه المصريه تتطلع الى ان
يسهم اتفاق السعوديه وايران في تخفيف حده
التوتر بالمنطقه البحرين املت ان يشكل
الاتفاق خطوه ايجابيه على طريق حل
الخلافات وانهاء النزاعات الاقليميه
بالحوار وطرق الدبلوماسيه الخارجيه
الاردنيه اعربت عن املها في ان يسهم
الاتفاق بتعزيز الامن والاستقرار في
المنطقه مجلس التعاون الخليجي يتطلع الى
ان يسهم الاتفاق بتعزيز الامن والسلام
المنظمه التعاون الاسلامي رحبت بالاتفاق
بين الرياض وطهران
بلى رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
بلاده ستعمل مع فرنسا على تطوير اسلحه
بعيده المدى وانظمه دفاع جوي بالاضافه الى
تدريب مشاه البحريه الاوكرانيه وخلال
مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع رئيس الفرنسي
في باريس اكد سوناك على ضروره انتصار
اوكرانيا في حربها مع روسيا مشيرا الى ان
الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا يساعدها علشان
هجوم مضاد لتعزيز موقفها التفاوضي
حذر مؤسس مجموعه فاجن الروسيه العسكريه
الخاصه من ان اوكرانيا تستعد لشن هجوم
مضاد بينما تشتعل المعارك حول مدينه كما
اعلن عن فتحه 58 مركزا للتجنيد فتنتين
واربعين مدينه روسيه لاستقبال المقاتلين
الجدد الذين سيدافعون عن بلادهم وعائلاتهم
على حد قوله
في بيلاروسيا اصدر الرئيس البيلاروسيه
الكسندر لوكيشن كوم مرسوما بصداعيه عدد من
ضباط الاحتياط للخدمه العسكريه حتى سن 27
عاما بالاضافه الى عشرين شخصا ممن تلقوا
تدريبات في البرامج الخاصه بتدريب ضباط
الاحتياط ويحملون رتبه ضابط في تلك القوات
قبل ذلك رجح مستشار مكتب الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ميخائيل بودليات رجعها ان تقوم
القوات الاوكرانيه بشان هجوم المضاد في
غضون شهرين وقال في مقابله مع صحيفه سامبا
الايطاليه قال ان القوات الاوكرانيه بحاجه
الى زياده امدادات القذائف من عيار
155 ملم لتنفذ الهجوم
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قالت سيده
اوكرانيا الاولى اولينا زينسكا قالت
تربطها علاقته متينه بالشرق الاوسط مشيره
لان هناك العديد من النقاط المشتركه بين
شعوب المنطقه واوكرانيا
اصبحت مقتنعه اكثر ان لدينا من النقاط
التي تجمعنا اكثر من النقاط التي تفرقنا
نحن نحب اطفالنا ايضا ونعتني بوالدينا
ونحب ثقافتنا ولغتنا ونطورها وعلى هذا
الاساس لدينا امكانات هائله اريد ان اقول
للعالم العربي كله اعرف انكم تفهموننا لان
جميع الناس الواعين يفهمون بعضهم البعض
وامنوا ان يستمر دعمكم لجميع الاوكرانيين
لاننا نحتاج اليه فعلا
سيده اوكرانيا الاولى وصفت اللغه الروسيه
بالنسبه للاوكرانيين بلغه الحرب معتبره
انه سيصعب على الاوكرانيين التحدث بهذه
اللغات بعد ما
حدثين من الصعب التحدث بلغه الناس الذين
جاؤوا لقتلك انه انتقال بسيط جدا من الصعب
الاستماع الى هذه اللغه وانت لا ترغبين في
استخدامها بغض النظر عن ان جميعنا نتقن
اللغه الروسيه بشكل ممتاز ولكن لا
نستخدمها لانها ليست لغه صداقه بالنسبه
الينا لقد اصبحت الان لغه حرب
تتابعون اللقاء مع سيده اوكرانيا الاولى
على شاشه العربيه اليوم في تمام الساعه
السادسه عشر بتوقيت جرينتش السابعه بتوقيت
الرياض
فاصل قصير نواصل بدر النشاط تفضلوا
بالبقاء معنا
[موسيقى]
ليس هناك ما يبرر ان لا يكون هناك سفير
لتونس في دمشق في الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه
وسفير للجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في تونس
مساله
النظام في سوريا مساله تهم السوريين وحدهم
نحن نتعامل مع الدوله السوريه اما
اختيارات الشعب السوري فهي اختياراته ولا
دخل لنا فيها اطلاقا
بمشاركه مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه
والاعمال الانسانيه عقدت جامعه الامم
المتحده للسلام جلسه نقاش رفيعه المستوى
في مقر الامم المتحده في جنيف بمشاركه
وحضور ممثلين عن عدد من المنظمات الامميه
العامله في الشان الانساني وعدد من
الدبلوماسيين والصحفيين والعاملين في
الشان الانساني الجلسه التي حملت عنوان
نظره عامه على الاوضاع الانسانيه في اليمن
ناقشت اوضاع المراه والطفل في اليمن
والانتشار الواسع للالغام وتجنيد الاطفال
والاعتقال خارج اطار القانون وشددت على
اهميه التعاون الدولي في العمل على تحقيق
سلام وسلام في اليمن وايصال لمساعدات
الانسانيه لملايين المحتاجين الذين يعيشون
في بلد يعاني من اكبر ازمات الفقر والجوع
حسب تصنيف الامم المتحده
ايضا يقوم مركز الملك سلمان بحل مشاكل
المصابين السابقين بمثل هذه الغرام وبدات
ممن فقدوا اطرافهم سواء العلويه السفليه
من خلال اربعه مراكز
لعمليه توفير الاطراف الصناعيه تعمل منذ
فتره تكلفت ما يزيد على 34 مليون
دولار والحقيقه تخدم
المصابين وتعيدهم لحياتهم الطبيعيه بعد
ذلك وتساعدهم ايضا على ان يكونوا اعضاء
فاعلين في المجتمع
وتصرف ايضا وتتابع عمليه صيانه اطرافهم
الصناعيه خاصه في الاطفال الذين تتغير
اطرافهم يعني كلما يكبرون وتساعدهم ايضا
على ان يجدوا وظائف من خلال برامج
معينه وتساعد ايضا الاطفال الذين يستخدمهم
المليشيات الحوتيه في زرع الالغام في
اعاده دمجه من خلال برامج متخصصه اشادت
بها الامم المتحده لاعاده ادماج الاطفال
الاطفال
المعنيين او المستخدمين في النزاع المسلح
مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه الاعمال
الانسانيه حريص جدا على دعم كافه فئات
المجتمع واهمها المراه وذلك لماذا تاثير
المراه على العائله وبالاخص الطفل الواقع
في اليمن جدا صعب ولكن الان نقدم برامج
فيها تدريب وتمكين وايضا مراعاه الصحه
العقليه والدعم
الاجتماعي والنفسي
للمعرضات للعنف من خلال التعاون مع منظمات
امنيه وايضا منظمات محليه اليوم قدم
المركز اكثر من 700 مشروع يستهدف المراه
وبشكل عام في جميع القطاعات سواء كان في
الامن الغذائي وايضا في التدريب والتمكين
مشاريع التمكين من المشاريع المميزه جدا
في المركز وذلك لتحويل المراه من اعاله
على المجتمع الى امراه داعمه لاقتصاد
المجتمع متمكنه لدعم الاسره واقتصادها
واحتواء خصوصا الاطفال رفع الوعي ايضا من
العوامل التي نهتم بها بالمركز رفع
الامهات بالاخص وذلك للحد من انتشار
الظواهر السلبيه في المجتمع اليمني
الشركه الام لفيسبوك انها بدات العمل على
منصه اجتماعيه جديده لمشاركه الرسائل
النصيه في مشروع يعتبره منافسا محتملا
لتويتر المجموعه الامريكيه اكدت في بيان
انها تستكشف شبكه اجتماعيه منفصله ولا
مركزيه لمشاركه الرسائل النصيه فيما ذكر
التقرير الاعلاميه انا تطبيق مثل جديد
سيستخدم تقنيه قابله للتشغيل المشترك مع
شبكه
ومنصات اخرى
وتشهد منصه تويتر منذ شرائها من قبل ايلون
ماسك مشاكل عديده خصوصا بعد القرارات
المفاجئه التي اتخذها لناحيته تسريح حوالي
نصف موظفي شركه وغلق مكاتبها مؤقتا في بعض
والعلم وكذلك تاخرها عن سدادات ايجارات
لمكاتبها مصطفى زارو رصد جانب هذه الازمه
في اوروبا
منذ اللحظه الاولى كان دخول ايلون ماسك
مقر شركه تويتر مليئا بالمفاجات اذ دخل
باستهزاء حاملا حوض غسيل في اشاره منه الى
التغييرات الجذريه التي سيقوم بها وفور
الاستحواذ على الشركه صرح الى الماسك
حوالي نصف موظف الشركه حول العالم واغلق
مكاتبها مؤقتا في محاوله لخفض التكاليف
وفرض قيم عمل جديده وفق ما يراه مناسبا
وان اتت بنتائج عكسيه
ما كان عليه تويتر لمستخدمي في جميع انحاء
العالم لم يعد موجوده فهي منصه غير مستقره
ولا يمكن التنبؤ بما سيحدث لها حيث نشهد
زياده في اللغه المتطرفه للغايه ومحتوى
يقول ماسك ببساطه انه حريه التعبير وللاسف
تجاوزنا هذه النقطه
لم تتوقف مشاكل تويتر عند تقليص القوه
العامله ولا التاخر في دفع مستحقات
ايجارات مكاتبها ومن بينها مكتب لندن هذا
بل امتدت الى الاعطال المتكرره المفاجئه
في ست مناسبات منذ اواخر اكتوبر الماضي
حرمت المستخدمين في جميع انحاء العالم من
التفاعل عبر المنصه او نشر التغريداتهم
الى جانب قرارات تعليق حسابات صحفيين او
اعاده اخرى ابعدت شرائح واسعه من
المستخدمين كما اوقفت كبرى شركات التسويق
اعلاناتها على تويتر ما ادى الى تراجع
ايرادات وارباح الشركه
ابقاء المعلنين على منصه تويتر والحفاظ
على انفاقهم امر بالغ الاهميه والسبب في
تخلي هؤلاء المعلنين عن المنصه هو المحتوى
السام الذي لا يريدون ان ترتبط اسمائهم به
وهذا يمثل مخاطره اكبر الان للعلامات
التجاريه لان القدره الرقابيه على المحتوى
في تويتر تضاءلت بشكل كبير بسبب تقليص عدد
الموظفين
هذا هو يطالب الاتحاد الاوروبي الى الماسك
بتعيين المزيد من الوسطاء ومدقق الحقائق
لمراجعه المشاركات وفق القواعد الاوروبيه
لمراقبه المحتوى عبر الانترنت
مشاكل شركه تويتر منذ تولي ايلون ماسك
زمامها لا تنتهي ما فتح الباب امام علامات
تجاريه منافسه للصعود في سلم مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي ورغم ذلك خبراء كثر ما
زالوا يعتقدون ان بامكان ماسك اعاده تويتر
الى ما كانت عليه اذا ما تعامل مع الشركه
على انها منصه رقميه عالميه وليست مصنع
سيارات مصطفى زاروا العربيه لندن
اسباب كثيره تقف وراء هجره الاطباء
المصريين من بينها تدني الاجور وضغوط
العمل وارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه نقابه
الاطباء حذرت من تزايد معدلات الهجره
وطالبت بتدخل سريع لانقاذ القطاع الطبي في
مصر مراسله العربيه في لندن والقاهره
التقيا عددا من الاطباء المصريين لمعرفه
اسبابه هجرتهم الى بريطانيا
اطباء مصر لا يشعرون بالانصاف هكذا يقول
من هاجر منهم الى بريطانيا فهم تركوا
قطاعا صحيا قالوا انه ياخذ منهم اكثر مما
يعطيهم لا ماديا فقط وانما معنويا وذهنيا
الدكتور مصطفى عبد الله والدكتوره هند
الديب من بين اكثر من 11 الف طبيب مصري
غادروا قطاع الصحه في مصر ما بين 2019
و2022 وفقا لنقابه الاطباء المصريه
ساعات عمل طويله او الموازنه بين العمل
وبين الحياه طبعا بيبقى صعب شويه وطبعا
مشكله كبيره جدا في مصر في مجال الطبي
الحكومي هي الفلوس وده برضو من احد اسباب
كبيره جدا اغلبيه الناس اللي موجوده في
انجلترا مصريين بيجوا عشان يطلعوا من هذه
المشكله ويجوا البلد ثانيه احنا شايفينها
بنحترم اكتر الاطباء وبتديهم فلوس اناف او
تديهم
يعني او تقدير من حيث مد او معنوي او او
احترام عامه في الشغل عامه امن عشره 15
سنه برده احنا مكناش على التواصل مع
الدكاتره بتوع تانيه فكنا فاكرين ان ده
الطبيعي
اه كنا عارفين ان في امريكا وفي انجلترا
وفي الدول
عندهم نظام احسن مننا كثير بس اللي
اكتشفناه اني لا حتى في دول الجيران دينا
في افريقيا واسيا عندهم ترينينج احسن مننا
بمراحل وعندهم او بتاعهم وكمان احسن مننا
نفوق لان لا
الوضع في كل الدول والدول دي مش هتحلينا
اقتصاديا في الحلقه الاقتصاديه وفي الحاله
التعليميه وفي كل حاجه طب ليه العديد من
الاطباء المصريين وجدوا في بريطانيا مكانا
لتحقيق احلامهم المهنيه سمعنا الاسباب
التي جاءوا من اجلها وروايه وصولهم الى
هنا لكن القصه لا تبدا من هنا تبدا من
هناك من مصر وزميلنا احمد عثمان سيروي لنا
هذه القصه من هناك
بالفعل ماذا حدث به عدد من الاطباء
المصريين المقيمين في لندن يمثل واقع
مؤلما لعشرات الالاف من الاطباء المصريين
كريم حسين احد هؤلاء الحالمين بالتوجه
للعاصمه البريطانيه متخرج منذ خمسه اعوام
ومتخصص في مجال الكبد دخله الشهري من
العمل في المستشفى الحكومي
4200 جنيه اي ما يقرب من 150 دولارا اغلب
الاطباء بيفكروا له جات لهم فرصه ان هو
يسافر ولكن ده مش هروبا من من اداء الخدمه
الطبيه في مصر ولكن بيبقى بحث للتعليم
الطبي ان هو يسافر يتعلم افضل يلاقي فرص
تعليم طبيه افضل بره نفسه الامل يسيطر على
اجيال اكبر احمد بيومي المتخصص في مجال
علم النفس تخرج منذ 13 عاما يركز حاليا
على استكمال دراسه الزماله البريطانيه
استعدادا للرحيل الرغبه دايما في عالم
البحث عن عالم جديد يكون في واجبات واضحه
حقوق واضحه نسبه التعدي على الاطباء اللي
ظهرت في المستشفيات اثناء ازمه كورونا
وفيما بعد قبلها وفيما بعدها يؤدي الى
نزوح كتير او تفكير كتير من الاطباء في
الى الخارج للتحصيل العلمي والاستلام
والبحث عن الامان الانساني والاماني
المادي ايضا نقابه الاطباء حذرت من
تداعيات هذا النزوح الكبير ده انذار كبير
جدا جدا وخطوره كبيره جدا ولازم انبه ان
مش زياده عدد الطلاب ودخول طلاب كليات
الطب هيبقى هو الحل زياده عدد وخريجي
كليات الطب سيؤدي الى زياده عدد الهجره
لابد من حل التلات اسباب اللي بيؤدي
الهجره الاطباء التدريب والتعليم الطبي
المستمر بيئه العمل المناسبه ودخل الاطباء
وقد تكون ازمه هجره الاطباء رساله جاده
للدوله بضروره سرعه اعتماد رؤيه جديده
للحفاظ على مستقبل مصر من الاطباء احمد
عثمان العربيه القاهره
في نهايه نشر هذا التذكير بابرزه عناوينها
ترحيب عربي ودولي باتفاق السعوديه وايران
وتطلع لاسهامه في استقرار المنطقه
بريطانيا وفرنسا تبداان الانتاج المشترك
لاسلحه بعيده المدى وتدريب البحريه
الاوكرانيه
ما يبرر ان لا يكون هناك سفير لتونس في
دمشق الجمهوريه
العرب قيس سعيد يبدي عزمه اعاده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه المقطوعه مع سوريا منذ عام
نهايه نشاط شكرا لكم على طيب المتابعه
والى اللقاء عند المنتصف
[موسيقى]